so today I'm not fucking around you are
gonna step out of your comfort zone
because I know that if you want to do
something that you're not doing because
you're afraid is it that open mic night
is it asking that person out is it
illegal experimentation we need to start
being okay with being uncomfortable in
fact we should start facing those
discomforts head-on what's the worst
that could happen
exterminate original I'm talking about
taking certain actions that you would
view as a life accomplishment or a fear
overcome whether that's public speaking
or pursuing a dream or something as
simple as telling someone that you like
them this video is actually inspired
because I am deathly afraid of singing
in public when I was in Middle School
there was this girl named Angela a blog
Angela if you're watching this I hope
you know that you scarred me for 10
years I was singing out loud in class
and Angela said heyo who the fuck is
singing so I've been working with my
therapist the past year to face
everything I'm afraid of and to put
myself for everything that gives me
anxiety
so I formed a comedy music duo with my
friend Megan Rosati we do a lot of
improv and sketch stuff together
we've been practicing the last few weeks
and I am going to be starting performing
live excited that's the word we use an
entertainment excited never nervous I
think whatever it is that you want to do
that you don't because you're afraid
that's all the more reason to do it I'd
like to thank Warby Parker for
sponsoring today's episode and for
making next month's short film possible
yes where we park ourselves high-quality
and stylish prescription glasses and
sunglasses starting at only 95 bucks as
you may have noticed in this video I had
like five pairs of prop glasses going on
and that's because I did their free home
try on program what's doing online
ordering for clothes and glasses you
know it's scary about the fit so they'll
send you up to five frames for free and
you get a prepaid shipping label to send
them back so don't worry about that and
when you order all you have to do is
upload either a picture of your
prescription or send them your doctor's
number the best thing about where Parker
is that whenever you buy a pair they
send one to someone in need you can go
to where we Parker Khan Anna and if you
order you'll get free three-day shipping
that's where we Parker comm slash Hanna
thanks so much for watching today guys
good luck
I'm dead right now Anna because you told
me to do something that scares me so I
jumped off a cliff and now I'm dead no
now you're good
oh my god it did but I need this for a
shot